you know as dope as the first project
was i feel like you leveled up with this
one i feel like it feels more cohesive
it feels just more personal like thank
you bro thank you that means the world
appreciate that for real took your time
yeah i did you know i feel like you
could have followed up with a you know
within a year with with the way the last
album went but yeah i feel like you
really took your time with this project
obviously you gave us like an ep you
gave us some some taste but like what
was
for you like was that on purpose to like
really not rush the sophomore album yeah
um now the string of things one you know
this pandemic right
i'm really a touring artist like i make
music to perform it
and um
two is like i always wanted to sort of
set myself up to where
i have a expectation
of taking my time with albums not an
expectation but it's just patient myself
career-wise i'm career-wise excuse me i
know i could always deliver a high
quality album every two years you know
if i ought to drop the album in 2020
like
back to back right after lost boy it
wouldn't have been good you know in my
opinion it wouldn't have been at the
level to where i needed it to be and so
i just really i had to live a bunch of
life honestly to talk about some new
things you know um
and go through some [ __ ] in order to
express that in the music
and um
yeah it wasn't a purpose it's funny
though the day that lost boy came out i
remember i told ace i was like yeah it's
probably gonna be like another two years
before i drop another album like [ __ ]
what and i'm like alright you gonna see
but and but i it's not like i'm just
sitting there for six months and then
i'm like okay i got a year and a half
left let's get it done like i'm working
every day yeah the whole time but
i just didn't want to rush it and just
put some [ __ ] out just to put some [ __ ]
out just to feed the algorithm you know
i just wanted
because i know i would look back like 20
years from now 10 15 years from now
however long it may be and be like i'm
so glad that i took my time with this
album
versus i'll regret it more if i just
rushed and put out album versus now i
took this time out
all this time and creating and
cultivating this album
and putting all the energy all my effort
into it versus just throwing some [ __ ]
out rushing it out just to put it out
plus if we think of like the all-time
greats right we're thinking like
kendrick we think
a lot of these guys nahs like you know
they took their time from i mean these
guys take their time like for sure
hole's not dropping every 12 months you
know what i'm saying for sure
yeah it's a couple is everybody got
their own path jay jay for a while he
comes every year every summer jay-z when
i was a kid
but you know yeah jay-z's the greatest
of all time for sure everybody got their
own path and it's not like i'm looking
at like a kendrick blueprint or like
okay kendrick dropped three years in
between his first and second now or two
years between his freaking seven now so
i gotta it's just what naturally how i
progress like i recorded hundreds and
hundreds of songs but i knew
um what i wanted to say what point i
wanted to get across and i just wanted
to make a complete cohesive body of work
and i knew
um i just wanted to
take my time not with like actually
creating but we're just finishing
everything up